today I want to talk about my struggles
with Korean I want to talk a bit about
how I have learned different languages
what the process has been for me where I
have had success and why and where I
have struggled some of the languages
that I have struggled include Korean
Arabic and I'm going to go into why
today I'm going to talk about Korean my
initial exposure to Korean was in 1972.
that's a long time ago my wife and I
were living in Japan we went to Korea on
a visit just to see it I was very
interested a country on the continent of
Asia some kind of language relationship
to Japanese in terms of being of North
Asian origin in its basic structure
agglutinative languages and of course
with an awful lot of boring from Chinese
in the case of both Korean and Japanese
and of course tremendous cultural
borrowing from China so I was very
interested had a great visit when Korea
was I guess considered a developing
country but it was really developing as
we now know I went again in 1976 a good
friend was at the Canadian embassy there
he was getting married he wanted me to
be best man at his wedding he married a
Korean lady so I did that at that time I
bought some books for learning Korean
and I'm going to show you my library of
books for learning Korean but I didn't
do much with it I went back to Japan
where again I was living at the time and
then in 1980 I visited Korea I was
working for atomic energy of Canada I
thought I was going to be very much
involved with Korea because Canada was
building a nuclear reactor in Korea but
in the end I only spent one year with
atomic energy of Canada then I went back
to the forest industry and so again my
initial sort of Spurt of Korean study
kind of went down the tubes but still it
was out there and then you may know that
in 2003 I wrote my book the linguist my
experiences in learning nine languages
which at that time didn't include Korean
and then we got started with Link at any
rate I said you know what I should get
back to Korean so I bought some more
books we didn't have Korean at link one
book which was very good which I really
enjoyed was the introduction to Korean I
think it's called Uh you'll see when
I'll show you my library done here at
the University of British Columbia the
narrator's voices were so good and
that's so important in any kind of
learning material you can't have these
Beginner Books with a boring narrator
just turns me off and that was kind of
the high point of my enthusiasm for
Korean also the book was full of
patterns language learning is about
patterns they had grammatical
explanations they had terms like
copulative verbs
strange but I ignored all those
explanations I just accepted the
patterns listened to the patterns listen
to the dialogues which were kind of
semi-humorous dialogues students
situations that I was kind of more or
less familiar with not too heavy on the
sort of cultural traditions and that
kind of thing which is more difficult
because less familiar and that was kind
of as I say the high point of my
enthusiasm for learning Korean so I
bought more books but more and more
these books they were also boring and so
I started losing interest and at that
time instead I became interested in
Russia and we had rashnet link and
pretty soon Berean was in the rear view
mirror and I was spending all my time on
Russian I spent a lot of time on Russian
there was very interesting content
political content literature audiobooks
so much good content we had it at link
and so I was off with learning Russian
and then Czech and then other languages
although I have made Regular attempts to
sort of restart my Korean and you'll see
here when I show you my statistics that
2010 at various times I said okay I
should put in three months you know 90
Day Challenge see what I can do to get
my Korean up to a better level and I
think I have improved or did improve but
then of course I didn't use it for the
longest time I'll show you a video at
the end here of me speaking Korean with
my tutor after one of my 90-day
challenges but still it was difficult at
link for a variety of reasons you know
we had some beginner content we didn't
have the many stories the intermediate
content was quite uninterest what I
attempted to do was find podcasts and
then I actually paid someone to
transcribe these podcasts so that I
could work my way through these but they
were very difficult I one was a literary
podcast the other was a political
podcast I just fought my way through
these it was so hard so many unknown
words and of course in Korean there's so
many little words that have eight
possible meanings and I didn't know
which meaning was appropriate and we
didn't yet have sentence view as we now
have where I could get a sentence
translation which would help me decide
which of the sort of translations of
that word was accurate I'll show you how
I go through Korean on linked today and
you'll see that there are more sort of
user hints other users who have looked
up words and I can quickly see the most
likely translation of a word and looking
at the sentence meaning I can get a
better sense of what it means none of
that was available before link was
slower before it was just hard going so
there were too many headwinds it was
just too difficult so I was always
attracted away to something else so you
know again thinking back to that sort of
high point of my enthusiasm for Korean
there is that quotation from
Shakespeare's Julius Caesar where Brutus
says there is a tide in the Affairs of
men which if taken at the flood will
lead to success or something so if I had
continued when I was most enthused and
if I had had less difficulty or if there
had been more interesting content
available or if link had worked better
or if the dictionaries were better if
all of these conditions if the
attraction had been greater and the
resistance had been less than I think I
would have continued and achieved a
better level however
all the effort that I have put into
Korean is not lost I have according to
my statistics some 40 50 000 known Words
which theoretically is a lot now in all
of these languages it depends on how we
count Words there are a lot of different
endings to words in Korean that you know
help Define the function of the word in
a sentence so uh it's not something we
can compare to other languages but I
have a large base of uh you know
vocabulary and even a comprehension and
my Chinese helps of course so that if I
were to go to Korea but I don't have the
freedom I have a family I have other
things that I'm doing I can't just go
off to Korea for two months and be with
people and speak Korean all the time but
if I were to do that I think I could
bring it up to a decent level
nevertheless I am disappointed I feel
that you know having first bought books
for Korean back in 1973 so that's a long
time I've had those books a long time
I've put a lot of effort into Korea if I
were to open up some of these books that
are on my bookshelf you'll see that
there's underlinings and tick marks and
all kinds of things but you know you
need to have meaningful interesting
content that you can stay with which I
have for Persian right now that you're
not deliberately trying to learn I was
too much deliberately trying to learn
the language rather than enjoying the
language once you get to where you can
enjoy the language even if the progress
is slow it's enjoyable I got to where
the Korean wasn't enjoyable it was work
and when it's a work you know I find
that it's harder to commit the time
necessary to be successful
so I'm going to end up here with show
you me working on Korean at link and
also after that you'll see a video as I
say of a conversation I had about nine
years ago after one of my 90-day
challenges so I haven't given up on
Korean but it's been a long time and I
haven't achieved what I would have liked
to have achieved thanks for listening
bye for now
yeah I just want to show you you know
how I uh study on link here I'm going to
use the computer version I could also do
it on my iPad you can see here that our
Korean page has improved tremendously so
we now have so much content here to
choose from literary audiobooks uh ab
workout uh you know all kinds of
different stuff getting started you know
we have our mini stories which we never
had before to that extent it's a lot
better I can even select the level that
I want to be looking at in terms of
content but I'll give you an example so
here's this thing I found this is a
imported from YouTube we now have the
ability to import things from YouTube
which wasn't the case before so here's a
lesson that I found in our library
I could have gone to YouTube to find it
myself but at any rate so I can click on
this thing okay so it's it's kind of
childish but something I might do okay
if I go here
so I can listen to the audio just for
that sentence I can look up individual
Words which I could do before but it's
much faster
so I have all these different meanings
we're still most likely one up at the
top show translation now if it becomes
more of a sentence you'll see here
foreign
content but it just shows you how link
has improved with the introduction of
you know the ability to import content
and I'm gonna I'm gonna show you this
but you can see that you can I can
import MP3 files ebooks lessons so I can
bring material in if I import an audio
transcribe the whisper AI will give me a
transcript so that I will create a
lesson from it so there's so many
different types of content that I can
use that the whole experience has become
much more agreeable
if I go to a website like chosen elbow
here and they've had floods and Korea
and if I pick an article about the
floods like this one and I go to our web
browser or browser extension and I can
import it
and it'll come into link so I can study
it as a lesson
all right we just wait a few seconds
while it comes in and I one of the
things that has changed compared to
previously is the tremendous
availability of things that I can import
with a click using our browser extension
from YouTube from articles in newspapers
and so forth I open up the lesson I have
a lesson all right you'll notice that
there's a lot of blue text these are
unknown words
I have about 13 000 words known words in
Persian and if I go import something in
the link and you will see that there are
far fewer new words having spent far
less time
on Persian I understand much more of it
look at this there's just two blue words
here uh you can see that in the case of
Persian
uh you know if I go to my all-time
numbers here I've been at it since 2018
and kind of like a peak known words
addition is like one thousand and that's
a peak most the time it's quite a bit
less than that if I go and look at my
Korean situation despite the amount of
time that I spent on it you know and and
you can see it goes back to 2010 and
there are days where I hit like 4 000
known words added now I'm helped by the
fact that I know Chinese and so I can
plow forward in Korean and I will add
more and more known words but it'll
still be difficult me so I have this
greater sense of just working and
working and not getting anywhere
uh in Korean as opposed to in Persian
egg
shells yeah
um
[Music]
cold food